hello everyone and welcome to the
penultimate round of this year's Super
bet chess classic we have a very
exciting game between yankeesht of Duda
and alireza firo jalireza who already
defeated three people in this classical
tournament and out of those three okay
he defeated Morgan Daniel there but he
also defeated the reigning world
champion being litten and the former
World Championship Challenger Yani
punishi and The Duda is still without a
win in this tournament he has one loss
he drew all of his other games so he
would very much um enjoy a win at least
with the white pieces in uh the the
penultimate round as there's only one
more round after this one so that being
said let's check it out uh quite a lot
to enjoy here so Duda has the white
pieces and he opens with the D4 we have
the five Pawn to C4 Pawn to C6 and
Knight the C3 uh Knight to C3 going
after the slav defense with a pretty
standard setup we have Knight to F6 C
count press on D5 C captures in the
bishop to F4 so the exchange variation
being played followed up Bishop to F4
Knight to C6 and now Pawn to E3 with
Bishop to F5 all the Fairly standard
staff Knight to F3 and now Pawn to E6
and here uh usually you will see Bishop
to D3 this is the most common move
Bishop to B5 is the second most popular
but instead we have a queen to B3 it's a
very tricky attempt by white okay going
after the B7 Pawn so you have to defend
against that with Bishop to B4 stopping
that and also pinning the Knight on C3
and now Bishop to B5 and this is a a
very tricky position uh there are even
classical games in the database that
reach this position uh where uh Black
Thought okay I'm just gonna play Queen
to B6 and everything is nicely defended
because uh if you capture my Bishop on
B4 is defended but they overlooked that
Queen characters on B4 is possible
because the Knight on C6 is pinned and
yes I'm talking about a classical game
the highest rated player to do this in a
classical game was rated over 2300 so he
made this queen to B6 move against the
2500 player so it's just something that
you know uh people do for for some
reason there just are these positions in
chess I don't know uh we should have a
name for the for that like it's a
position where it doesn't matter how uh
how uh High the the player is rated he
will he will make a silly move so here
we have castles which is a great move
and now just Bishop captures Bishop
captures on C3 Queen captures and C3 and
now you could play some like Rook to see
it but first we have 94 attacking the
queen queen to A3 and not B captures on
C6 we have Rook to C1 going after the
pawn and now you might expect something
like Rook to C8 but no alireza once
again he plays Pawn to G5 and he goes
after the white king now the bishop is
attacked you have to move it Bishop to
G3 and okay there is one game uh where
Queen the B6 was played it was played uh
in a game between uh Patrick van Holland
and a game at Kafka uh in um
uh in 2016 in in Novi Sad But Here we
have rooked the C8 and it is now as of
move uh 14 that we have a completely new
game so Knights the D2 uh trying to get
rid of this annoying Knight on e4
because for the moment it is the
strongest piece on the board Knight
captures on G3 H captors and just King
to G7 so you can push H5 you can put the
Rook on h8 and so on as white does have
the semi-openh file we have rooked the
C5 now uh either preparing to move the
king maybe double up on the C5 put
pressure on the C Pawn or just shifting
The Rook to the a file and going after
the A7 pawn and there doesn't seem to be
all that much all it is I can do about
this so he goes Rook to h8 with Rook the
A5 going after the A7 pawn and now just
Rook the C7 uh preparing to trade Rooks
here if do the trades and then alireza
wants to shift the attention to the king
side even though he's down a pawn and
The Duda says alright I don't really
have a say in this Rook captures an A7
with Rook captures Queen captures and
now Ponte h 5 all it is that goes for
the attack and the difference on the
clock is Duda has an hour on the clock
alireza has half an hour on the clock
and here we have Pawn to B3 uh which is
which everyone thought was not the most
precise idea because the engine was sort
of saying you have to play Knight to F3
here uh because you then you get the
Knight the E5 but also the engine shows
that with um you know decent defense it
doesn't really do all that much let's
say G4 Knight to E5 Bishop to G6 and now
okay a human will leave the Knight here
and uh probably put so much pressure on
black that at some point black will just
crack crack Under Pressure uh but the
engine says yeah just add captures and
G6 here it will be nice for white but a
human no way that a human gives up this
Knight for for a bishop you know it's
something maybe Fisher would do and get
a brilliant surprise for it but I don't
know you just don't see anyone doing
this so This does seem like it could be
the way to go but instead we have B3 now
he wants to start advancing that pass
Pawn to Victory and now we have Ponte H4
again all it is I could play Ponto G4
but it seems all it is that doesn't care
about Knight to F3 so he just plays uh
Ponte H4 and now okay we have characters
on H4 G captures and H4 and now Knight
to F3 now Duda will get his Knights the
E5 the shot to G6 and now even Rook the
H3 first with Queen T8 offering a queen
trade and to do the happily trade with
captures captures
uh and now as the A2 Pawn is hanging
Pawn to A4 we have Bishop to C2 now
going after the B3 pawn and we have a
trade Rook captures an H4 Bishop
captures on B3 and The Rook to G4 check
with King to f8 and now Rook the F4
going from for some Knights the E5 uh
but also Knights the G5 ideas uh this
will put pressure on the F7 Pawn but
also on the E6 spawn as the F Pawn is
pinned and now uh basically we have to
decide where to put your king where to
put it on G7 or to put it on E7 E7 is
much better but alireza does none of it
he plays Rook to A7 and one of the
reasons why probably alireza decided for
this is that he was a very low on time
so here Ponte A5 sorry Aponte A5 now
again if you move the Rook here let's
say Rook captures then then it comes the
G5 and there's the thread of Rook
captures here and also the thread of
Knight captures on E6 so you don't have
a rogue back to A7 so instead after this
A5 move with Bishop to A4 now the
situation is 3 13 minutes on the clock
for Duda and only 6 minutes on the clock
for alireza and we have Pawn to A6 uh
another tricky move uh the point is if
you go for something like Knights the E5
here putting pressure on the pawn here
then King the G7 can be played and now
if Ponte A6 then for example Pawn to F5
and it's hard to say probably white will
be able to play something like G4 and
then let's take him to F6 captures here
captures here uh White uh will have the
advantage of a better Pawn structure
being a pawn up and you should be able
to do something about this let's say
Rook the H4 and then you push for
Advantage but instead do the one for the
immediate Pawn to A6 and now we have
Bishop to B5
uh interestingly alireza made that this
move with four seconds on the clock he's
playing uh this uh uh just an increment
and uh okay you can play this but uh it
seems that C5 was uh probably the way to
go here point is that after d captures
and C5 and Rook captures on A6 Knight
the E5 comes going after the pawn you
can play this bishop to E8 move that's
why C5 was so strong as it clears the
path for the bishop to retreat the E8
square but of course he was a very long
time Bishop to B5 was played and now
Knight to G5 is just incredibly strong
you cannot defend against Knight
captures on E6 uh so here Bishop
captures and A6 was played Knight
captures on E6 with check King to E7 and
not knighted back to G5 putting pressure
on the F7 Pawn King to f8 still fights
uh somewhat fights here but after Pawn
to F6 now Duda is completely winning if
he is precise Knight stage seven now the
pawn will fall F5 Rook captures on F5
Bishop to D3 nicely connecting here but
there's Rook to E5 of course this comes
with check King to D6 and now Knights
the G5 and here do this up to pawns and
of course the ones that uh G Pawn starts
marching up the board you cannot um
uh save the game anymore if the bishop
here was defended then you could harass
the white king with rookie one check
rookie to check rookie one check and
then you would either win the F2 Pawn or
get a Perpetual unfortunately the bishop
on D3 is not a defendant so Rook day one
checking D2 just comes with an Attack
under the ship so instead Rook to A2 was
played going for Rook to e to check but
now Knight to H3 Knight to F7 check um
uh is perhaps a bit more precise but the
Knight H3 also is very nice now you
don't have to worry about the F2 pawn
and now we have a bishop to C4 and now
this is move 39 and alireza has to be
very very careful here because Duda
played Pawn to G4 and now alireza has a
chance he can actually get uh uh get
this position maybe to a draw but he has
to again find Point pawn to C5 but he
has one more move to make the reach time
control and he actually played it with
two seconds on the clock but he did not
go for C5 he played Rook to E do with
check just to show you why C5 is so
strong now of course the pawn cannot
capture The Rook with Hank here so you
would move the Rook Rook the A1 with
check and after a few checks you're
listening to D2 Rook data with checking
to C1 King to C6 you will play Rook the
fate and now C capture Sandy for E
captures and Rook to A1 with check who
play King to B2 Rook A2 check you will
play King to B1 so no more checks Rook
the D2 going after the pawn here and
this is now sufficient Knight will come
to F4U we'll pick up the D4 pawn and
you're now down only one pawn and you
have uh well more than excellent drawing
chances however alireza played Rook to
E2 with check
now of course you don't go to F1 under
the mask of the bishop so King to D1 was
played and now Rook to A2 we have Pawn
to G5 dude that just starts advancing
his past pawn pawn to C5 now alireza
finds the move that he should have
played a few moves ago but now it is too
late we have Pawn to G6 Bishop to B3
with check with King to E1 and Rook to
A1 with check King E2 we have Rook to 80
with check King to F3 and now Pawn to C4
alireza also creates a pass Pawn uh but
now Rook to E8 not allowing The Rook to
stop the promotion of the g-pawn so here
Rook the A7 stopping Rook to G7 but now
yeah dude that just ends the game in in
a single move I'm sure you guys can see
it because the pawn covers C5 and D5 uh
dude that just plays Rook d8 with check
and it was in this position animal 48
that alireza firucha resigned to the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here the problem is as we've said you
have to go up the board you can go here
and um well if you go to E7 or or uh C7
doesn't really matter just G7 and then
the the pawn is defended if you go for
something like King to E6 then we just
slowly bring the king up the board of
course there's no point in playing this
and if you go away from the pawn then
that's uh obviously even worse so all
you guys I had enough of this it's uh
too ugly uh position the plane yeah so
he he just resigned here and
interestingly this is duda's first win
in the tournament and uh even though it
kind of ruins alireza's chances of
winning the tournamental it is is still
uh doing excellently on the
understandings these are the standings
after eight rounds of um this incredible
tournament so Fabi is leading with five
points and then in second place we have
alireza Wesley so Anish giri and rihad
Rapport tied with four and a half points
then with four points Maxima Sherlock
and young she used to do that with three
points Yani punishing uh and Bogdan
Daniel Dak so sharing basically uh last
place
so we'll we'll see what happens in the
final round uh will Fabi take it or will
uh some of the other gentleman alireza
Wesley Anisha Rickard have something to
say about this uh and uh maybe take the
tournament for themselves but as Fabi is
in Seoul lead uh that means that if Fabi
wins he is definitely the winner and I I
can't remember which tournament it was I
think it was maybe 2018 or something
Fabi was leading the tournament uh by
half a point in the in the final round
and then he just won uh so you know
maybe maybe that will happen uh we'll
see how it goes as he is playing
incredible chess uh so yeah that's the
game hope you guys enjoyed it I would
like to thank amazing thank you for
videos Dr Heisenberg ding fan and
revision reptiles YouTube for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of this
incredible event until it finishes ah so
thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day